did you go to the met last night or two
nights ago how I know it wasn't known I
don't know we talked we talked about us
two nights ago
okay we did a full fashion review on
this show oh yeah I really your thoughts
are on fashion yeah um you can't trust
like out-of-work lesbians
i am i separately I went to I went two
nights ago how was it it was uh like I
got through it you know it was like I
felt good about how I looked on the
thing and then it was just uncomfortable
if I could have been comfortable I would
have stayed longer but I was like out by
10:30 what is it like I know I know
everywhere oh yeah they're in there yeah
everybody kind of mingles around these
tables and there's a dinner and then
musicians perform and I'd go with I went
by myself
you want my you're Simon Zac Posen made
my dress but I yeah I just went by
myself and I like a bunch of friends
there though I literally walked in and
the first person I saw was Kim
Kardashian just kind of standing there
and I was like I can't are - Ian and she
was like hi
and we sat down and we hung out for like
a half-hour and we talked and I was like
and she was I'm not kidding and I know
this is going to get really trashed on
the show but she was like really
insightful and I'm dead serious
down-to-earth that's amazing no she was
so cool it was like I was it kind of
kind of [ __ ] me up like she said she's
changed a lot since I brought the
robbery and the robbery yeah the genes--
gun put in her face and maybe that
matter how good you're doing yeah but on
your face really does uh make you feel
like this could all go away very quickly
yeah she was I don't know what she used
to be like but she was like a realistic
guy no I'm not kidding didn't get mad at
you for that time you fell down in front
of them no that's another thing she she
doesn't give a [ __ ] she were talking I
go I'm not gonna put any of this because
we were like really talking and she goes
oh I don't I don't care she think I
really don't care right and she didn't
you know when someone's like oh I know
you can
she doesn't care but she's literally I
mean you talk about somebody's head the
whole world say everything imaginable
about her right but to even be still
surviving in the industry she's got to
have some kind of ridiculous fix against
some resilience yes yeah